our first year of being global we
thought we would actually go on a road
tour and just meet directly with these
three designers the coolest thing about
this is really introducing a new
audience to these people are you never
get tired of driving around Paris most
of the city was designed by one person
there's nowhere else in the world that
really captures that you come to France
and you want to be a Frenchman or a
French woman it's a culture that's
steeped in design thank you for every
boko you have more creativity in France
so I said thank you for us we're here to
meet Amy because he's the coolest
designer on the planet he's badass it's
amazing
ah
and these about reality when I say
reality is about the way live my life
here in Paris
[Music]
my name is Alex Thomas you see I'm the
designer and founder of Annie Smith I do
that all the time
sketching sketching people yes oh I love
MySpace yes but not the right not the
right fabric yet this is gonna be in
gray this is gonna be in black and red
oh good good stuff but we just need to
yeah perfect
I mean you have to think that these
pieces are all gonna sell out within a
day or two I hope so
100 stores of the best gap stores all
over the world like this I really like I
like it because it's got the nice fits
kind of the French comfortable in the
shoulders and then it's like a little
bit more relaxed Pleakley in process
this is the first time I see the pieces
love-a-lot logo this is a logo that we
created like few few months ago we call
it a media I didn't want to make
something crazy forget for me gap enemy
have the same philosophy about clothing
you know we doing clothes right and I
take it like very seriously but I have
to make it like
the team alone we all share the same you
know and choose yes indeed everyone
wearing on me
shall we your army very close team here
this is my spin loop then I was with
them other days let's go like if it's
not fun it doesn't make you know happy
you walk into all three of your stories
it's a very very personal experience it
gets you a very excited about the
clothes everything of the story is
perfect it's everything you really want
and he also gives you the opportunity to
buy and put it together in your own way
he is the master of subtlety I mean
that's a brilliant t-shirt look at that
t-shirt and I think anybody who buys on
me understands that the clothes are
incredibly well-made you can see how the
stripes line up on the pockets that is a
color that only the French can do those
are the customers right there it's a guy
who like really loves simple clothes
they have a lot of character to them
[Music]
more natural you look more interesting
you are Bon Appetit
[Music]
what's the way that you you disrupt your
process but still so keep your keep the
soul of the clothes of course I'm
changing you know and I'm getting older
I'm turning 37 this year I becoming more
precise in my choices you have to lose
yourself a little bit sometimes to
realize that it's a very nice detail
I've never done that before I like that
as a kind of a conversation throughout
the whole yeah
we're doing a fitting of a gap
collection love to see the clothes on
him I will say like making a collection
is like writing a piece of music you
need to get like you know a balance and
harmony and sometimes you need like high
notes sometimes you have low notes but
the mood and the harmony of the general
composition of it it is like to make it
like very very mellow you know in a way
it has to be easy I don't want like
close makes you like feel like you know
intellectualize or conceptualize
everything you have to think too much
has to be like easy Paris was awesome
but now we're going to Tokyo and I
couldn't be more excited we looked at
the Japanese for their incredible
individuality masters together the
neckline as it is now it might scare a
few guys off from buying it